l'âme d'immersion confirmé lors d'une
récente exploration du fond de l'océan
le sonar des scientifiques a enregistré
un saut aucune oreille humaine n'avait
jamais entendu une animation et
nickelodeon movies présente
la recette du pâté crama disp à
marseille la ville en proie à la
révolution et au chaos post bac tu
rajoute un peu c'est l'apocalypse c'est
super tout pour sauver leur monde ça
sommes pas des crabes
ça vient de là où la surface ok bon bah
tous les personnages secondaires avec
moi ils vont débarquer dans le nôtre
c'est quoi cet endroit bizarre il doit
le savoir lui c'est à bâle un nul à cinq
têtes barbe à papa vous avez de figure
pour attendre depuis longtemps le sucre
en 2015 tu m as des craintes qu'ils
pourront utiliser vous marchez tu te dis
c'est ce qui m'arrive quand j'ai le
travail c'est la seule façon d'arrêter
la soupe est dit là bas on va dire mais
c'est de devenir des super héros
janyk
ono mot patrie comme le boire mon ami
lumière blanche là ça va mieux merci ya
mieux 3 et compte le film aeros hors de
l'eau en 3d la vengeance est un plat qui
se mange glacé
on aurait pu choisir un autre super
pouvoirs patrick